heather pas ce drame n'a pas de tendre
et 10 pour les sapeurs pompiers de
vendôme après plus de 300 appels en du
jour pour cause de tempête voici à
produire leurs propres interventions
trois choses ont été servis en plein
champ par la montée des taux
il faudra bonheur trois hommes
grenouilles des pompiers pour récupérer
un à des animaux et les mettre à l'avant
où il
puis hier matin
aujourd'hui la nuit
c'est pour se stabiliser à deux mètres à
vendôme services multiples
les services de sécurité civile
on les tue aux rives
sous les barrières son éventuel
tu sais toi
les prévisions et les niveaux du loir
constaté dans le département de lot rôle
de l'eure-et-loir nous laisse penser que
le loire va continuer si à vendôme de
monter sans doute jusque dans la nuit
ensuite pour plus tard je ne sais pas
parce que moi même je ne sais pas si
dans les heures qui viennent nous allons
ce cas de jeu
5 à porto par avance en 83 l'eau avait
atteint deux mètres quarante est avalisé
à l'effort
350 associations le pouvoir on est
encore loin de son seuil critique
mais cette nouvelle fut pouvoir risque
d'écorner pour certains
koné